ALEXIS MP: Hi there.
We're here back at Devoxx.
Exciting conference so
far, lots of content.
I have with me the Chrome guys.
So I have Joe, I have Francois.
These guys have been here
talking about Chrome Apps.
And I'll start with you Joe.
Can you tell us what
Chrome Apps are, even?
And how they differ
from maybe, real apps?
JOE MARINI: So they're
relatively new.
We officially launched
them back in September.
We've been developing them
for a couple of years now.
Essentially, Chrome
Apps are a way
to use HTML5 to develop real,
native-feeling applications.
Applications that look
and feel like native ones.
They run outside the browser.
They work offline by default.
They work on desktop
as well as mobile.
So it's a great
way for developers
to build real
native experiences.
ALEXIS MP: A lot of things
you covered briefly here.
You want to cover
the offline part?
What does it really
mean to be offline?
JOE MARINI: Yeah, sure.
So we're all familiar with
building web applications,
right?
So you use HTML5.
You build your web application.
It's online.
So when you build
a Chrome app, you
build it the same way,
HTML5, JavaScript, CSS.
But all the resources
are packaged up locally
into an application.
It's local on your machine
like an installed app is.
And you can run the app
when you're not connected,
or when you have a connection
that's not so good,
and it just behaves normally.
ALEXIS MP: Great, so
that's really, obviously,
very important.
Another thing is you can
access computer, the laptop,
or the machine's resources,
as in the USB port,
or the file system,
and stuff like that.
So that brings up
the ability to build
a whole new range
of applications.
Which typically a
web app could not.
JOE MARINI: We leverage
HTML5 wherever possible.
But when HTML5 does not
provide a certain feature,
we have Chrome app
APIs that fill in,
for things like file access, and
USB and Bluetooth, and sockets.
ALEXIS MP: So one of the
reasons I have Francois here
with us also is that's Francois
has been doing some of that,
which is integrating
with some of the hardware
available on machines.
Do you want to tell
us more about what
you're doing here at Devoxx?
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: One
guy, actually in Google,
named Louis, built an
awesome library on JavaScript
to be able to communicate
with those USB NFC reader.
So what we've done is, we've
built a Chrome app which
helps with registration.
And basically those tie here.
ALEXIS MP: So the wristbands
that everybody has here.
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: And you
can scan it and write to it
directly from a Chrome app,
only with web technologies.
That's just awesome.
ALEXIS MP: It's used
here for registration,
for delivering the
wristbands, checking what's
on those wristbands, which is
used throughout the conference.
And we use those on Chromebooks.
But that could be on any
machine that's running Chrome,
which kind of brings
me to the question of,
how are these packaged
and delivered?
I mean, those Chrome Apps.
JOE MARINI: So
basically, it depends.
On desktop machines, they
are packaged up as zip files
and they are stored in
the Chrome Web Store.
And so you go to the
Chrome Web Store,
you download and
install the application,
and it's the same
as you download
an app from any other app store.
On mobile, we use
the Cordova library
to package up applications
as native apps.
So they're basically native
apps that host your web code.
And they get packaged as a
native app for that platform.
So for Google, they
go in the Play Store.
For iOS they go in
the Apple App Store.
So depending on whether
it's desktop or mobile,
that's how they get delivered.
ALEXIS MP: How real are
Chrome Apps today on mobile?
How far along are we?
JOE MARINI: Well, it's
really early days right now.
We have a team of
people in Canada,
in Waterloo, that are working
on contributing to the Cordova
effort.
We've got a good set of the
core APIs ported over now.
We think that
probably by early 2014
we should be in good
shape for people
to start building real apps.
ALEXIS MP: So how would somebody
go about building an app,
pushing it out, and
making it known?
So there's a store for that?
That's how people
find out about it?
JOE MARINI: To build
it, it's really easy.
You can go to our website.
It's developer.chrome.com/apps.
That's where all the information
about the APIs are stored.
If you want to go to Github,
we have a Github repo
at github.com/googlechrome.
Then there's a Chrome
app samples repo
in there, shows all the samples.
So those are
probably the places I
would start to learn
how to build these.
ALEXIS MP: Great.
Francois, how hard was
it to actually build this
once the library was available?
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: Once
the library was done?
So easy.
And we are hoping to make
this library open source
so that anyone can use it.
ALEXIS MP: It's
interesting to be
able-- NFC is obviously
not built in every machine,
but certainly devices
like this one has it.
It'd be great to be able to tap
into that kind of resources.
Any final words on
where to go next?
What you expect from this
technology going forward?
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: Oh, dammit.
JOE MARINI: We're building
new APIs all the time.
We've already got a lot of great
apps in the Chrome Web Store
that some great
partners have built.
So we're continuing to see
some really good uptake
in the platform among partners.
We're looking really forward
to getting these things out
on mobile.
We're really looking forward
to people building mobile apps.
So I think that it's early days.
It's just beginning,
and I'm really
excited to see where it goes.
ALEXIS MP: Great.
I think I heard good
things about your session,
certainly here at Devoxx.
And people can catch
it soon, and [FRENCH].
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: And
if I can add something--
ALEXIS MP: You should.
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT:
So, Chrome API, great.
But my hope is that
we'd be destroyed
in a matter of years so that
the web can [INAUDIBLE].
ALEXIS MP: So you're saying
HTML++, 5+, whatever,
is the standard.
JOE MARINI: It would be
great see a lot of this stuff
get standardized over time.
ALEXIS MP: But you need
to start somewhere.
JOE MARINI: Got to start
somewhere, exactly.
ALEXIS MP: Chrome
Apps, check it out.
FRANCOIS BEAUFORT: Woo hoo!
ALEXIS MP: Thank you.